it's a free hit for you guys this
morning
well it's not a free hit really because
i wish we weren't in this situation i
mean i think it's very difficult for
boris johnson to reconcile what he said
at the dispatch box where he said there
wasn't a party with these pictures that
have emerged when there's sort of
bottles of drink everywhere he's merrily
toasting the assembled gathering but
for me
i mean it's just depressing really
because we've got this awful cost of
living tsunami coming we know that the
price of everything's going up in the
shops we know the elite of petrol is
going up the energy bills are rocketing
you need a government
focused
on the cost of living crisis putting in
place measures to get more people into
work to grow the economy instead the
government are completely preoccupied
with boris johnson's political survival
and not the financial survival of the
viewers and that is depressing because i
want this government focused on those
issues but instead we've got the lying
prime minister
you know it's not really in the national
interest for him to continue in office i
mean tory mps i mean they'll tell you
privately they want shot of him it's
time they grew a backbone and got rid of
him um that picture that we've seen of
him in the papers this morning mirror is
the one of your boss no it doesn't
because first of all boris johnson said
at the dispatch box in parliament there
was no party that day and i'm i've been
around this place long enough to
remember that
it used to be the case that if a
minister lied at the dispatch box
they're out on their ear so but boris
johnson says it wasn't a party well i
mean there's people now
briefing saying he was there for 20
minutes saying he was topping up the
drinks that he that he orchestrated the
gathering but as i say for me the issue
is he lied at the dispatch box
and the sole focus of this government is
boris johnson's political survival is
not focused on the pensioners who who
need plumbers to come and uh you know
fix their heating because they're so
cold those pensioners sitting on the bus
all day to keep warm those families
struggling to feed their children that's
what the government should be focused on
but instead it's all about this soap
opera this drama this divided
conservative party uh ripping each other
to shreds where over this mess would be
better if we could move on from this get
rid of boris johnson and focus on this
cost of living correctly speak to you
again though that picture more or less
mirrors what your boss was doing in
durham well well it i don't think it
does actually he's got a drink in his
hand but it's a gathering and there's
food on the table first of all that
picture is at the time when we're
supposed to be in a full lockdown
kia was uh campaigning at a time when
campaigning across the country was
allowed and was having a work meeting uh
i think it was doing work events and
then stopped for something to eat and i
drink while doing work box was on the
chair so he was still working he was not
working there's empty bottles of drink
everywhere he's toasting them i mean
there is a bottle of sanitizer so there
is a nod to some of the covid uh
regulations that were needed at the time
unless they were drinking the sanitizer
i mean there's a lot of the
which i hope not but bloody hell
couldn't who knows i'm sorry you're not
allowed
but i mean i mean it is look there are
bottles of drink everywhere but the key
thing is boris johnson said at the
dispatch box there was no party there
clearly was
um
well you heard from the transport sector
he said it wasn't a party he was
literally passing through a little he
stopped for a moment a bit like your
boss did
well you've now got people briefing
saying he was there for 20 minutes and
he organized this but as i say for me
the key issue with this is that he lied
at the dispatch box and secondly he
should be focused on this cost of living
crisis and he isn't focused on it
because the whole energy of this
government is focused on boris johnson's
political survival when you've got
families struggling to pay their bills
making choices between feeding their
electricity meters or feeding their
children we've got pensioners sitting on
buses to keep warm this is where we need
the focus and action from government and
yet it's all about boris johnson and his
and whether he survives or not well it
will be until we see the sugre report
but the police have looked at this and
they said there's no case to answer well
that's the operational decision for the
police but i think i think sadiq khan's
now said the police need to explain uh
the decision that they've taken so i
mean i think
you know let's let's see what the police
have to say about it
do you think they need to explain
themselves well i mean i think you know
policing is my concern in this country
so i think they i think they probably do
need to
explain their decision-making process
but these are operational decisions for
them and it's not for me to put
political pressure on them at all no but
i'm asking you whether you think they
need to explain yeah i think i think
people probably do once because
everybody is asking questions quite
legitimately you're asking questions on
politicians i think your viewers will be
asking questions about it as well so i
think they do need to explain it but
equally boris johnson needs to explain
why he lied on the dispatch box uh
and
why he is not focused on the issues
facing the country okay when you talk
about issues facing the country you
reference wigan of course with uh
last week quite a few challenges for
some of the people in wigan as you know
um what more do you want the government
to do they are looking at a windfall tax
day well they're looking at it but
they're paralyzed by an action aren't
they i mean they could impose a windfall
tax and those huge profits the energy
companies are making but you know when
the prices are going up in the shops by
so much you also need extra help to help
pensioners to help those who rely on
universal credit you could bring forward
some of the increase which the
government have budgeted for for next
year
to this year because at the moment a
pensioner is getting a 500 pounds real
terms cut in the value of the state
pension there's no reason why people
need to wait a year actually as you said
budgeted you know they've pushed it they
don't have the money no they have but
they've said they're going to do it next
year yeah so they could actually bring
that forward and you know the last time
inflation was at these runaway levels in
the 70s actually the labour government
at the time brought in a second increase
in the pension and other support in the
same financial year so there is
precedent for it they could actually do
it if they want it but their inaction
means 250 000 households pushed pushed
into destitution 500 000 children pushed
into absolute poverty many of them in
places like wigan i don't think that's
acceptable okay um as far as the
government is concerned they've said
that they're they're putting cost of
living concerns
on the back burner that's my
interpretation until after the report is
out
your thoughts on that they need to be
getting on with this they could do a
windfall tax today would if they if they
needed to pass it through parliament
we'd vote for it they could bring
forward support for pensioners today
would support it they could bring
forward support for those on universal
credit today we would support it they
should put in place a plan to get more
people into work i'm outlining today how
i want to reform employment support
because i'm a reformer i want to reform
employment support to get more people
into good well-paying jobs as well and
yet in this queen's speech the other
week they abandoned the employment bill
and other measures there is action they
could be taking but they're not how do
you feel about the rail unions going on
strike well
the rail unions and the management of
the railways have got to get round a
table and negotiate a deal a strike is
always a sign of failure if we get to
industrial action that's a failure of
negotiations now the problem is workers
obviously deserve a fair pay rise given
that wages have been squeezed by and
inflation is credited outside so that's
coming but they have to obviously spread
the money around nurses and and
very many other workers who are equally
deserving i mean advantage ups should be
moving heaven on earth to help
the unions and management come to an
agreed negotiated settlement but again
grant chaps is touring the studio saying
it's not a party there isn't any problem
again this just shows you how boris
johnson's rule-breaking and lying is
taking up all the energy and focus
of ministers when there are real issues
out there and grant champs should be
focusing on that not being sent out as
the sort of safe pair of hands minister
for the broadcast rounds in order to
defend boris johnson the rail strike
will cause all sorts of problems though
for people um and food on the shelves
etc etc so what would you say to the
unions this morning well i would say to
management and unions let's negotiate
a deal let's give a fair pay rise to
workers but let's get a deal because a
strike is always a sign of failure
nobody wants to see strikes and actually
by the way
workers
uh only ever go on strike at the very
very last resort they don't want to go
on strike you know that impacts them and
their families so they want to see a
negotiated deal but it's incumbent on
you know ministers to bring those both
sides together and get a deal hammered
out and there's still time to do it the
minister could do that that's what he
should be focused on today not touring
the studios to defend boris johnson's
lying